[Music]
welcome to fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I'm mark Barnard yes such a
delight to be here it's been a minute
since we've been here
thanks for coming out this afternoon
early show it's like four o'clock is the
I know I feel like a senior citizen is
there a buffet or something like that
we're doing a pretty early show here at
the scum and villainy Cantina our home
for fat man on Batman right here on
Hollywood Boulevard in Hollywood
California put your hands together so
the folks know that you're real okay
what have you been up to I mean I've
been here I don't know where you've been
I was making flash yeah I was working on
flash for the last month it was fun we
had a really nice time it was a good
funny episode there's people are gonna
see it me like you [ __ ] jump the
shark with this but but I don't it's
very funny there's some witty witty [ __ ]
had some visual jokes and and I was
delighted at how like it's my third time
now doing a flash how and I hadn't done
one in a while last one I did was killer
frost episode last season so it's almost
like a good over a year between episodes
that I did and how like I always talk
about like I don't know how to direct
like I'm a [ __ ] idiot
but I do know how to direct and like it
it's always surprising me when I'm like
oh [ __ ] I know how to do this and I got
us out like early and [ __ ] like that on
some nights not because I'm like good
just because I'm like I could put
together scene in my head where I'm like
we got that that that that sometimes
they get directors in the do like a lot
of coverage cover everything to death
use every lens and the kit I'm like one
lens ten minutes let's go we're done you
know so I was able to move things along
get people home early and stuff like
that we did a good weekend and it's a or
good few weeks and it's pretty fun
episode and let me I guess I could spoil
it here don't tell anybody
yeah don't [ __ ] share this at one
point like you know I did my first
episode of Flash
and they asked Jason Mewes to be in the
episode he was up in Vancouver so I was
like he's always by my side so he'll be
there anyway absolutely so this time
around there's a scene that had two
security guards in it and so the writers
of the episode Kristin and Lauren
Kristin Kim asked me specifically she
goes
we were wondering like do you think you
and J would want to play the security
guards and I did and honestly I did not
want to do it because I knew it required
I'd wear pants like there's only so far
in the world I could take this outfit
and believe me I've stretched it to its
limit like anywhere I go I hosted a show
for History Channel last week I was
wondering the [ __ ] jersey with an H
on you know it's like I treat my [ __ ]
Jersey like a NASCAR car you just put
all [ __ ] stickers all over it brand
me like [ __ ] and whatnot but I knew if I
was playing a part like where I wasn't
being me I had to be like a security
guard I couldn't be the security guard
in jorts so you know I they probably
would cut that so I knew I'd have to
wear an outfit and [ __ ] which included
pants so I was like oh [ __ ] I don't want
to do it but I knew if I said no I'd
never hear from the other guy I'd never
hear the end of it because he felt like
we had a chance if he I'll [ __ ] flash
together and you didn't [ __ ] take it
so I said all right we'll do it and they
suited us up like security guards and
for the first times I think since my
father died I wore dress pants and I
looked at myself in the mirror and I was
just like so [ __ ] glad that I made
clerks cuz if I had to like wear pants
for a living like I don't I don't know
if I could do it man like I just don't
have a body built for pants I really
don't so we shot a scene Jason and I
were we play two security guards in the
flash and it's it's it's not Jay and
Silent Bob
but Jason speaks and I don't so there
you go but it was fun man it was good
[ __ ] time so he's in that episode 17
it's called Nolan annoyed I'll let you
know when it's happening nice yeah I
mean but you realize if security guards
get booze to stand behind
right yeah but it couldn't we had the
action called for us to be like out and
exposed and stuff like that it was a
wrecker though right I was what you're
the director you be like you know what
let's change this I'm gonna be behind
with donuts yeah just chilling right
back here I could have no pants I just
well the director has no [ __ ] power
and TV all the power belongs to the
producers the creators the writers as
you know so even if I was like my guy
standing behind a booth with donuts to
be like no he's not like [ __ ] put
pants on you know and then I'd get into
this whole ethical discussion 1 so it is
weirder is a weird moment where I
realized something about myself where I
you know I'm always like I got no limits
I do have limits and it's [ __ ] pants
like the moment I put pants on I'm like
powerless I feel like like when Samson
cuts his hair and [ __ ] like I just can't
do what I got to do the jorts are like
now a big part of the whole thing I
think you're liberated man below the
knee literally I guess but at the same
time a slave to never not wearing pants
you know what I'm saying like there's
there's something there like freedom
true freedom would be me pulling pants
on and being like I'm still a big boy
but like I can't do that nope sorry man
I as it's like we're not gonna [ __ ]
figure this out tonight dude as a person
who wears pants on the regular I don't
have that much sympathy for you yeah I'm
just saying you're one of those [ __ ]
sheep I know put on pants leave the
house take a show what what have you
been up to wearing your pants I won't
tell you what I've been up to not
wearing my pants though
okay now this has been like this has
been the three weeks in which every nerd
journalist who happens to be of any kind
of color has been the busiest in the
[ __ ] world because there was a Black
Panther movie they came out and and
people expect black people to have
sayings and feelings about Black
Panthers which you know it's fair fair
because all of us do yeah so yeah
there's been a lot of press I was I was
on the Fox television networks what I
know not Fox News they don't like
literally I would burst into flames if I
cross the threshold even if they invite
me in but
I feel like a [ __ ] noon on FOX 11
Aloha local Fox
well like tell us what Black Panther
means what did they what did they call
you Mark Barnard in under your name uh
local Black Panther fans I tried to get
them to do like dazzling urbanite but
they did not go for that whether they go
for it
they went for writer / journalist not
[ __ ] podcaster man you could have
plugged the show I know I'm out there
every day fat man I'm Batman I'm living
the [ __ ] fat man I'm Batman
what was the light going on Fox and it
was not talking about our podcast at all
do you do a podcast no no I don't know
why would you think that that would be
weird
I'm a grown man I wear pants don't you
say that it was so [ __ ] weird because
when I was a kid I went to college at
st. John's University in New York and
that university pretty much a [ __ ]
seriously dude for real I'm DMC in the
place to be I went to st. John's
University you went to the same [ __ ]
colleges damn City I did I didn't meet
him though doesn't matter but when I
went there they were all about pumping
out technicians for live television so
they had you know like editors and
cameramen and boom operators knowledge
it so they had a full-on control room
and a full-on TV studio with this at
this university it was basically just a
bunch of [ __ ] fat dudes sitting
behind cameras not really wanting to do
the work that these kids were telling
them to do but sounds like my biography
but there were always people there and I
go to this Fox station and everything is
[ __ ] automated all the cameras are
robots yes which is so [ __ ] eerie
because you walk into this this room
that's cavernous and there's nobody in
it but the two people on TV yeah and
just everything is just swimming around
you it's like [ __ ] Runaways not the
cool hooli show but the gene Simmons
killing people with robots show the Tom
Selleck movie yeah steep pole [ __ ]
cut it was a little bit scary yeah like
and they say watch out for the robots
and I've never heard that before on a
new convention floor in New Jersey into
a quick
quick check and went to check out there
was nobody there
it was just robotic registers and I was
like this is clerks 3 ok but so yeah I
couldn't understand it yeah like that's
they don't tell you that that's how the
robots how long ago eight minutes is it
[ __ ] you up being on TV so like still I
don't care who it is when it is if I'm
on TV I'm like oh my god I used to watch
TV yeah so like it still impacts me does
it a little [ __ ] weird it is a little
weird
Desalle people you call people are gonna
be on Fox I called my mom I sent my mom
a text about the History Channel show I
was like watch this show and she goes
that's too late he's 11:30 at night
she's never seen comic book man either
I called my mom and then had to break
the news that well no you don't get that
Fox that Fox is a different Fox like you
get Ernie Anastos on Fox in New York I
get other weird people who were kind of
Latino here in LA right she can't watch
this now but you watch it online yeah
and it's funny there was oh my god so
she'll never be able to check you call
her we could be like mom I'm on TV again
that's what but you can't see it I
robbed a bank but you don't know there
was a I went to opening night of Black
Panther the Thursday night at the
ArcLight and and it was amazing was
magical it was it was like Church but
for people who love superheroes but
after the showing there was like 50 or
60 guys out there and in like 20 or 30
women all of which work in TV in some
fashion couple of actors a couple of
actresses but a [ __ ] ton of writers
should you recognize a lot of folks
recognized a bunch of folks it was like
you know the barbecue that you got
invited to and didn't know that
everybody else got invited to but you're
all glad that you're there and so
somebody took a picture of like 40 of us
just kind of standing there like
thrilled to [ __ ] be there and that
picture got him Brandon Easton posted it
and he said well here's here's 40 young
african-american men young was very kind
of him all of which soup-to-nuts make
television like their show winners their
staff writers there's any and all in
between and we're all here and we're all
[ __ ] so proud and so thrilled to be
here and that photo went viral like it
ended up in like [ __ ] deadline and
Hollywood Reporter and
something like 20,000 retweets for a
dude who's got like 500 followers on his
account and my mom sees this photo and
she and her and her sister-in-law are
trying to find me in the photo and it's
like Where's Waldo cuz I'm really [ __ ]
short and all of these dudes are like
six one and six two and handsome and
strapping and young and my mom's like
where were you in the photo I know you
were in the photos again I'm in the back
mom I swear to God
but you were there right you know I was
there I promise you just like me just
like you're always on the news mark but
but no it's it has been a really like
heartwarming at times and maddening like
three weeks
well I maddening because you didn't make
Black Panther that's why I was a damn it
it's it's maddening because for all of
the amazing warmth and all of the
wonderful feelings in this this great
communal spirit that's been rallying
around this movie it's always like the
10% of the people who were like oh what
could it been white panther who's that
the internet mark I mean you know like
last week we did a black panther
roundtable here at the here at the old
scum and villainy bar and it was the
Monday after after the movie opened and
we had a you know it was me and then a
guy who wrote some background the comic
books and a couple of other black TV
writers and producers just kind of
talking about the craft and there and
the feeling and the what seems to be a
movement around this movie and some dude
on the YouTube comments which I know I
should not read but I'm a weak man I was
like what they couldn't find a white
dude to talk about Black Panther I mean
yeah yeah I'm gonna talk about it with a
white dude in like a week
just like give me like a look I gotta
talk about everything with this one why
did we just hang out for a minute but
yeah I mean there's always gonna be
somebody wants to pee in the pool but
yeah who gives a [ __ ] cuz it's been
amazing the it has been and I love the
movie I talked I did a review and it's
up on the channel already and I think
they put it out on the audio version fat
man I'm Batman as well but I pointed out
in the review and I was waiting for
someone else to jump on it man like
other people but nobody else
my first cinematic appearance of black
panther net civil war before then even
before that in 1989
Spike Lee do the right thing kids
hanging out on the corner are literally
shaking reading throughout the issue
throughout the movie issue of Black
Panther and at one point bugging out
wants everybody to boycott Sal's like
sad we're gonna boycott you fat pasta
ass and he's like you try it so he's
trying buggin out trying to get
everybody to boycott Sal's and it talks
to some of the kids they're like no way
and Martin Lawrence is one of them
and it's like as good as that pizzas is
and [ __ ] like that and one guy goes
black panther eat pizza because they're
reading a comic book and in the comic
book Black Panthers eating the pizzas
peace beautiful so he goes black pantry
pizza we pizza boy and that's it so it
was a really [ __ ] funny moment in the
movie and that was like one of the
earliest movies that I've bonded with
the young Jason Mewes over like you know
I've showed him do the right thing and
he was like oh my god is hysterical and
then it becomes very socially conscious
at the end he's like what happened you
know it was like that's Phil you know
and so we loved that [ __ ] movie
together and we would always say that to
each other for the last [ __ ] since do
the right thing was 89 so I don't know
we coming up on what 40 years almost
since that movie 30 years 40 or 30 years
30 [ __ ] yeah but since then man I've
been saying him and I haven't saying
black panther pizza weed Pizza Bowie and
now there's a Black Panther movie
everybody's saying it you were there
first yeah man we were there first the
first two white guys is there sorry to
crash Black Panther Party I did yeah
that I did see somebody on Twitter go I
won't see a superhero based on a
terrorist group or something like that
thinking the Black Panthers but that's
somebody who doesn't use the internet
correctly because all you have to do is
look up the dates and be like oh the
comic came first you know and then you
could be comfortable if even if that was
your one [ __ ] way not to watch and
also the internet will tell you that the
Black Panther Party was not a terrorist
organization there were community
organizers and they did as much good as
they did anything else and it was a
mostly good yeah there's that too and
you know I was just going for the Jack
Kirby Stanley
and I like the reason why they were like
so strict gun control laws is because
the government was afraid of the Black
Panthers because they bought a lot of
guns and they were like okay so we
should have laws restricting people
buying guns because of black people
buying guns fYI the internet told me
this I don't know but it's triggers on a
history lesson we tapped a vein I know I
should get a shirt that has a big H on
it too yes all right do we have anything
else to get to before we go did you like
the movie I loved it did you not see my
review I saw there was a review yes I
did I loved it i gosh I wanted to be
here in the presence of you and find out
what you thought of it you know for the
[ __ ] what did you expect I expect you
to let me what texted you what's your
problem with him I told him like my
problem with it and half an hour later
he's like would you stop telling what's
your problem with it is what was your
problem is that you just want to talk
about your problems with I love Black
Panther what was your problem with it
that I am less moved by touch Allah as I
wish I was so you do have a problem with
it I dad wasn't [ __ ] around neither
was i no okay wait explain that out my
problem with with the movie is that too
Chawla as your hero has no real dramatic
urgency he doesn't want anything hold on
he wants to be king and he is king ten
minutes into the movie credits and you
left early
I was efficient ryan coogler well done
according to me Mel a short film that's
amazing wait so that don't count like a
he doesn't do anything to become yes he
beats Baku but it's like he was gonna be
king yeah he gets to be king and then
it's oh [ __ ] now I'm not King that's
like an hour and 10 minutes into the
movie when he loses spoilers you guys
all saw it all right I mean I want to
[ __ ] anybody's day up if you were gonna
go after this you're right oops
I'm trying now think about your right I
guess he doesn't yeah I mean and so for
much of the movie it's like I need to
preserve the what kind of way of life
and I got to keep the status quo status
and I got a I just got to go along to
get along I don't want to do anything he
defines that his dad was a little bit of
a liar and his dad did some fucked-up
dad [ __ ] and there's a crisis of
conscience and then I got my ass kicked
by kill monger and then I died and then
he's like not there for ten minutes and
then is I'm alive again and then I got
my throne back and then all right that's
all cool but for a good hour that movie
he's reactionary he's very reactionary
and the great ideas in this movie the
what do we do with her Conda don't come
from him kill mongers idea is let
Wakanda have an empire let's rule let's
bring our our wealth and our science and
our everything into the world and this
[ __ ] takeover nikki is like we could
do outreach we could save refugees we
could we could heal the world we could
do it the right way we can do the work
on the way and to both of those to tell
us like now I remember that moment yeah
he's like nah man that's [ __ ] up and
then he's like actually though yeah and
that's his big dramatic turn is that the
entities like let's build an out you
guys were right I was a little bit wrong
he'll name it in honor of Erick kill
monger hall like change the name and
change the name yeah wow that was your
beef I didn't I didn't bump into that at
all yeah I mean my beef was just I
wanted him to wait what is what is
Superman wanted Man of Steel let's not
go using Man of Steel as some
bulletproof what about what does Peter
want in spider-man homecoming Peter
wants the girl
Peter Peter wants to be accepted Peter
wants to be embraced Peter wants to not
have to hide himself that much Peter
wants everybody around him to be able to
accept him for who he is including Tony
including happy including the pretty
black girl even including Mei who we'd
like to not have to keep secrets from
mm-hmm you know and and it is like I
understand spider-man story it's the
story of the [ __ ] teenager wants to
be grown-up and nobody will let him and
so you don't see that into Java
no lark not that particular but I think
there's there's there's ways in which
you could have underscored that a little
bit like don't make him King right away
make him after earner love make him not
be a great King off the bat like he
shows up and everybody loves him like a
Koi a loves him the kia loves him his
mother loves him we have nothing but
faith in you the council is all on his
side like you're gonna be a great king
just don't go off and do the same [ __ ]
your dad did but hey you you held
nothing but promise and we believe in
you like maybe don't believe in him so
much let him earn it let him earn it
make instead of that first fight with
mbaku that when he gets crowned king or
if that's a funeral for takaka what if
it's like if you want to show me what
Conda you want to show me the world
which that sequence is incredibly well
make it about honoring the past make it
about the lineage make it about we're
burying the last King and then the next
time when he challenges and kill mongrel
challenges that's when he's gonna be
crowned king and he loses like then then
he's got some like rising action he's
got something he's trying to do trying
to prove himself to everybody around him
and fails approving himself until the
very end when he earns the crown right
that I kind of by not again then I
[ __ ] dislike the movie I love that
movie you're just improving it as always
I'm just tinkering yeah I don't know I
mean I'd watch that version - but I
didn't bump into that as much on this
and I've seen it three [ __ ] times and
now that guy I'm drawing a line in the
sand but I'm not gonna go see it's not
like you saying anything is gonna hurt
this movies man this movie can't be
[ __ ] stop it has already made 548
million dollars worldwide this is what a
day nine day nine could be the fourth
film in history to make a hundred
million dollars in its second weekend oh
really
yeah that's true Wow we're just [ __ ]
nuts so there's a good chance so that's
worldwide that's domestic the five is
just domestic the five is worldwide the
hundred million dollars that second
weekend domestic so there's a good
chance that it could maybe hit a billion
I I think there's almost no way it
doesn't this is bigger than Wonder Woman
well that's what eight eight hundred
nine
yeah and it didn't open in China yeah
it's China gonna be a tough sell maybe
maybe not like fantasy oddly seems to be
a tough sell in China mm-hmm they seem
to have a weird issue with black people
but I don't know in that everywhere else
the poster was of Chadwick Boseman and
then in China it's black bear with a
mask on well maybe if we don't show you
his face you won't know that the black
panther is a black guy I don't know
maybe it was just like look some cats
want to see the black panther yeah
all right well [ __ ] it's all good thing
you're not gonna ruin the movie for me
[ __ ] you mark barnard hey listen
I'm going what come to forever I enjoy
it I talked about in the [ __ ] as one of
my favorite moments the moment that made
me well up was I I thought Michael B
Jordans villain kill monger was one of
the most fully realized villains in a
Marvel movie yet where you're like I
understand that [ __ ] Ark like at the
on one hand you're like oh you vile
creature but at the same hand you're
like well of course this happens like
you know and and there is nobility
behind like why can't we release this to
the world why are we sitting on this
mobile it's complicated it's not as
simple as look I hate this mustache
twirling villain and [ __ ] like that
he's got levels to him but when he be
spoilers when he you know takes over and
then he takes the root and then lays
down they bear him the sin and he goes
to see his dad
T'Challa went to see his dad and his dad
like he hugged his dad and there's there
was like a motion deep emotion and they
talked like buddies and [ __ ] and they
were right in the same place when he
went to see his dad there was a distance
and it was like broken it was so
heartbreaking because his dad goes no
tears for me mm-hm and he's just like
you know everybody dies or something
like that oh it was so sad like you just
you realize like this is what happens
because this kid's dad was killed he was
left behind
on a [ __ ] park in Oakland and stuff
really powerful moment that you never
really see in a comic-book movie it's
pretty one if there's there's so much
depth to this movie like somebody take
me on the on the Twitter's today and was
like he retweeted this thing to some
dudes head which is do you realize that
the climactic fight of this movie
takes place with two black guys
literally on an underground railroad I
was like holy [ __ ] yes
Wow and again that is the conversation
like rhymes not keeping that a secret
like he's now like guess what guys it's
gonna be a book a railroad don't tell
anybody
it's now hey Disney I'm gonna spend like
40 million dollars your money doing an
entire CG sequence with these two guys
fighting each other on an underground
railroad they're like yeah all right go
ahead have a good time I feel stupid for
saying but do you think he was conscious
of that I I mean you you were a
filmmaker far more than I am I'm here
yes I was a filmmaker far more than you
were and I remember one point reading in
the newspaper like we shot clerks in
black-and-white because we couldn't
shoot under the the fluorescent lights
in the store with color film we would
add very color time it would have been
expensive and [ __ ] like that so I'd ask
Dave Klein in one point I was like what
happens if it was black and white he
goes it doesn't matter there's no color
there it's just brightness and then we
can shoot under the lights in the store
that's [ __ ] let's shoot in black and
white that is cheaper so when the movie
was done we took it out into the world
one of the first reviews written about
it was just like the movie is shot in
black and white as if from the
perspective of the security camera in
the store and so from every interview
there forward I was like well we shot in
black and white because we wanted to
have to be Lemay's on scene of like the
security camera in the store so I never
thought of that I read somebody smarter
than me thought about nice stolen [ __ ]
do you think that was layered in there I
think so I think I was about to [ __ ]
deep cuts that's clever
Vanity Fair had this this sequence where
it was like Ryan Coogler analyzing a
particular scene of his movie he had
like the [ __ ] of telestrator like he's
doing like I saw that and and he's
talking about the the color story that
he's telling in the movie is the casino
sequence and so Nakia into Charl and a
coy walking into this casino and in
Busan South Korea and Nicky is wearing
green and two challahs wearing black and
McCoy is wearing red he's like well
those are the three colors of the
pan-african flag green black and red
it's like come on [ __ ] you're
not telling me a story in the costuming
in the costuming second then sequence
when she rips off a wig like the wig
representing the sort of Western world
and the way people sort of subdued their
own cultural specificity and so she rips
off the week and flees it into the face
of her oppressor and then punches them
in the wig like shooting by accident
none of it's by accident and so the fact
that it's underbelly that suits a really
good film is not [ __ ] quarter of a
century and I'm like oh you can do that
that's very layered and textured yeah
and I did read today that that the
composer guy named Ludvig goranson name
is the sweetest of swedes guys heads
scored he wrote music for a 4-hour cut
of that minute I read that somewhere
yeah so somewhere is the long ass
there's a long [ __ ] cutting how long
was this do you know 15 to 14 it didn't
feel that didn't feel long at all kind
of moves it moves very well but yeah
like there's an absolutely world in
which we get a 4-hour cut of this movie
all with like original music and let's
talk about Letitia riot holy [ __ ] my
favorite Disney Princess yeah Cherie
hands down in the comics she becomes
Black Panther at one point yeah I hope
they do that for a minute or two in the
sequel she was wonderful and the brains
of the operation totally and the heart
of the operation I mean I [ __ ] the
laughs - I call them sneakers well I
mean I talked about a little bit when I
when I did my little review that and we
talked about it there is absolutely
world in which when when our DJ boughs
out of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
which will happen at some point yeah
that if you need a hyper-intelligent
super brilliant inventor slash action
hero I mean she could out build that
armor in a in the comics in a minute
it's RiRi
it's Ruby Williams so now what you're
saying is there's a world where they're
like why not let Serie B what do they
call revie's character iron heart heart
yeah sure Eyrie Williams [ __ ] yes yeah
man she was wonderful what a find and
fun to watch somebody who seems to be
having a good time while doing their job
and just kind of all brightness
John who else did I like in that movie I
mean the cast was great across the
boards but oh [ __ ] I mean you know I
know he's revered as like he [ __ ] did
Gollum you idiot but I was not a [ __ ]
Lord of the Rings guy or anything like
that but this was like the real like
first kind of oh I get it
her Andy Serkis moment for me be as an
actor not just the guy wearing the green
suit and making Planet of the Apes and
stuff he was [ __ ] good man and he was
having a blast like he seemed to be
enjoying the [ __ ] out of his part as
[ __ ] quick as it was spoilers there
needs to be the ulysses klaw SoundCloud
link because I will listen to that [ __ ]
right now
it's great get into some code link
when's the next one so the next flick
we're looking forward to is Avengers
that's yeah and it's right now late
February and that happens in May mm-hmm
right on so and between now and then any
other that happens before that no that's
after right we get oh my god my heart
stopped that was a good stupid another
reason to live so there's Deadpool is
Deadpool's when Avengers Deadpool and
solo and bang bang bang yeah it's like
my childhood come to life when like they
used to have great [ __ ] epic movies
come out week after week after week and
yes even the summer time yet no I mean
it's I mean I'm pretty sure so February
I know people are like worried and stuff
but but my god what a great time to be
alive oh my god three [ __ ] fantastic
movies in a row red and circuses that's
all I wanna I would give like two less
great movies to have like the rest of
the world not suck this much but if it's
gonna suck anyway stop being so selfish
yes I will happily take wrinkle in time
when's that that's very singing days
yeah March 8 I've been seeing posters
for that all over the valley and stuff
yeah that's about to happen Reese
Witherspoon's in it though I'll get
through it she's not into much though is
that right I seen it did you read the
book material I read the book when I was
like nine
in like elementary so he's gonna be huge
yes give me a man make all the monies I
mean whatever money is that black
panther will leave oh my god how much
does that lead us into the news how much
black panther is it time for the news it
is time for the news we're gonna segue
into the news folks we're ready to
[ __ ] talk about the [ __ ] that makes
the fat man on Batman whatever how much
has it made so far five hundred and
forty eight million dollars worldwide
said that I forgot it's all right no wow
let's [ __ ] Hugh yeah do you know like
there was there was a little bit on what
it was on be to you something that
Donald Glover and his brother Steven
wrote jokes for black panther Donald
Glover Donald lover lando calrissian our
land Oh childish gambino Chavez Gambino
really yeah yeah like it
well he's isn't writing like a Deadpool
cartoon a Deadpool cartoon he just
finished Atlanta this guy's talented
he's all over to join yeah he said Ryan
was gracious enough to be like will you
take a look at the script
he told Entertainment Tonight Marvel
locks things down so we didn't have as
much happens wanted that a couple of
hours to punch up some jokes and so and
there are so many [ __ ] laugh lines in
that movie that are said like don't
scare me like that colonizer
nice like white person yeah yeah yeah
smart so I mean and that's when you knew
right then and there like oh [ __ ] we're
gonna see [ __ ] Bucky
that's the broken white boy she's
talking about
where is Captain America because at the
end so wait at the end of the Avengers
were know at the end of Civil War he
dropped off Bucky and they put him on
ice and they were in Wakanda but he
wasn't sticking around he's like I'm
gonna leave to me her [ __ ] off he's got
to go be Nomad I guess he went to rescue
everyone else from the is that what
happened oh my god I'm so ashamed to
call myself a storyteller that's right
that's what happens I thought that was
some impressionistic [ __ ] avizo
there for you but he literally [ __ ]
showed up so he drops Bucky off but that
PS scene happened after
yeah it's that order how do you know
that it [ __ ] you
how do you know that did I miss that
somewhere when he goes to rescue people
okay so but I'm fine I'll buy into it
but it's opinion right all right but
they don't put pokey on ice until the
proposed Alaska that's that's the last
thing you see I still think it's
subjective I don't think that's [ __ ]
bonafide and [ __ ] I was gonna give it to
you but that's that's more subjective
than anything right right either way but
in any event that's the idea as he
dropped him off from what that's what
you think he dropped him off from
Wakanda and then went and rescued
everybody else and we know all those
cats well I'm about ant-man but like
they're in the run and Wakanda Shaw and
the Avengers trailer right right so is
that all the people that was in the jail
but the Hulk he wasn't in the jail right
and black widows there and black widows
there the closing credits aren't always
the strongest threat excellent point
okay all right enough about that hey we
have Batman news oh [ __ ] that's I know
right on a show called fat man I'm
Batman
okay bye speaking of which let's plug it
up man or plug it out Justice League is
available right now on it iTunes and
video and DVD and blu-ray okay home
video now you can watch it at home and
[ __ ] yeah bring the magic go home I
could say so many things if I got a
story to tell her don't I got a story to
tell man maybe not yet I'll wait one
more time so you gotta come back to
March 6 to hear the story he's gonna
tell let's see I don't know we'll see
what happens it's weird
boy every time I would tell the story
there have been two times where I was
first asked to go be the host of or a
[ __ ] moderator for to Warner Brothers
events small not like premiers or
anything like that but definitely like
with full cast involvement stuff and
twice now like it's been kicked back at
the last minute which means somebody
high up is like [ __ ] him he does that
podcast and I've been trying to think
like what if I ever [ __ ] it like if any
of them always blowing these Warner
Brothers movies I mean they're blowing
them but I'm blowing up me know what I'm
saying like so you know you're the guy
that's always like they [ __ ] stare
now so maybe you're getting me in
[ __ ] trouble guilty by association it
might be I'm sorry
cuz I'm always the one that's holding
out hope and I was like yeah well the
flash was fast
you know [ __ ] like that by the way I'm
gonna be moderating a Justice League
panel okay so what is the Batman was not
really bad manners as Batgirl news
remember about a year ago they said hey
we're making a Batgirl movie and and
Joss Whedon is gonna write it that was
like after they announced like he was
gonna fill in for Zack Snyder thank you
on Justice League
yeah and they [ __ ] big fanfare and
everybody was like hey he did Buffy you
know oh but he also did like Black Widow
and uncomfortable [ __ ] to that character
and but hey but Buffy though right there
was some level of excitement there were
some of them ambivalence it's not
happening anymore he walked away he he
walked away and there was much rejoicing
there there is a I guess blurring of the
lines whether he would walked away or
whether it was a mutual fire here man
the optics just aren't good on a guy
doing a movie about a heroine anymore
like now that who directed
patty Jenkins is directed Wonder Woman
it's like there you go how about you
give a woman a movie about a severe a
woman to a woman make like there's a
novel approach so that just that just
feels right you know it's like and and
you know I'm sure there's a bunch of
people on the internet that will make
the argument like how about the best
person gets the job or whatever
well how about we'll find out when they
give that movie to somebody and they
make it and it turns into something but
like why not after years and years of
the same people directing these movies
give it to somebody new that makes sense
I hope it was Joss stepping away going
like you know what [ __ ] it ain't
worth it I mean he also said I don't
have a story to tell
after a year right he couldn't figure
out a Batgirl story to tell which which
may have been like a nice way of being
like maybe I should back away from this
you know what said I don't know I mean
look let's be honest it's not like
Justice League made people happy
or something like you fixed it and [ __ ]
like I think that there was a story
based on this story about the bat him
dropping out of bat girl that I read on
Twitter and now we're being species
because I'm documents back it up but you
can look it up on Twitter Zack Snyder
liked some story about Jos dropping out
of bat girl which fed fuel to the fire
to another story that's been quietly
building lately which is he didn't step
away from Justice League he was fired
and was not happy about Jos coming in
and and finishing it yeah I think it
goes that third Warner Brothers gig good
I didn't say anything I'm just reading
the news maybe that's what I'm in
trouble for being gossipy and [ __ ] but I
didn't write I read that online yeah I
mean yeah it had never occurred to me
that maybe like cuz based on the story
we were presented you know Zack was like
I'm stepping away for really great
reasons but it sounds like maybe that
wasn't your case I think that also
somebody's wrapped in the idea that Zack
has been someone removed out of the
power structure of DC films when he had
won points I mean the architect and is
now absolutely not
you know anymore and and it's funny
because out of this came this amazing
Twitter thread where Roxane gay writer
author also written some black panther
comics tweets out hey
DC I have a Batgirl story to tell in the
first response to that was from a VP at
Warner Brothers like for real email me
Oh awesome and you know the idea so that
Warner Bros VP er it was a Warner
Brothers who's one but it's one of those
yeah that means movie it sounds like oh
give her comic books I want to write a
movie and you know again the idea that
that I could do I have a backhoe sir
it's all probably not I could find one
in a year I'm just saying
cuz you know there's a bunch of comic
books that I could read but I just do
that one right Batgirl year one is
amazing just do that one but yeah in the
in the climate that we're in in the
world that we're currently living in
then absolutely we should see what a
Batgirl story told by a woman feels like
and what it looks like it has the Wonder
Woman and patty Jenkins taught us
nothing it's like there you go yeah and
hey you know [ __ ] hire somebody to do
it and if they do it it doesn't work out
right how somebody else like try it but
the excuse to not try it anymore doesn't
seem to be valid absolutely true the
director from ladybug a ladybird Greta
girl a better girl Wiig could be a what
good choice good choice
[ __ ] I yeah yeah she's a lady she's a
lady I mean she puts it on Front Street
it's right there in the title of the
movie it's very true yeah man it's a job
that's up for grabs they'll be curious
to see who gets it but either way I
[ __ ] can't wait to see that it's a
good idea to make a bet girl movie hell
yeah good idea to make a bat woman
series too man like they can go deep on
Batwoman there's so much there's a lotta
there's a lot of texture character to
play with a lot more story there well
I'm not gonna say a lot more story
Barbara Gordon's wonderful but I mean
with the Batwoman story you get yeah I
mean and that's one of the things that
have been partly conversation about more
interesting yeah Black Panther at about
diversity to representation and and
there was talk that that apparently they
had shot a scene in Black Panther where
one of the dorm Ellijay was voicing her
attraction to another member of the dorm
Elijah who was a homosexual
not even subtext texts seen that in the
four-hour cutter that movie existed and
in the two hour and 14 minutes cut of
that movie got dropped and you know
Black Panther can be a lot of things to
a lot of people but it can also be an
arc for every representational desire
that people have like it's got to tell
its story
but there have not been any stories
about overly out superheroes or even
characters and superhero movies right
and so if you want to get into that if
you want to get him set in a real way
the Batwoman kind of gets you there
it does instantly yeah and it also gives
you like a man-bat it's right there
people seem excited about that
all right so that's so do you think she
winds up getting the gig I think she
winds up having a couple of meetings I
don't know what her story to tell she
has but I mean she's a fantastic writer
but if for nothing else than the [ __ ]
PR of it and also just like this is this
should make agents very afraid because
if talent could just like reach out to a
studio and the void and be like hey I'll
do it they'll be like okay come and talk
you've just eliminated the middle band
or a woman that was a new Santa for what
yeah yeah exactly
interesting in other Joss Whedon news Oh
while he's not writing a background
movie anymore he is gonna be writing
Buffy again uh as a series as a movie as
a comic book as a comic book he had
written the Buffy the Vampire Slayer
book for Dark Horse for a couple of
years with other writers in between here
and there and then Brian Lynch I believe
is one of them yeah there's a bunch of
guys who had been part of that little
baby writers room and so he's returning
to the buffy comic books to write season
12 the reckoning for Dark Horse gets to
play with his toys again yeah since the
people won't let him play with their
toys he has his own toys he does have
his own toys I could respect that yeah
you were a big Buffy person I was a huge
[ __ ] Buffy person were you yeah
massive I'll tell you this much it is
shaped [ __ ] episodic adventure
television ever since then because they
still use terms that they implemented in
Buffy in the Buffy's writer room
Buffy writers room that they do on flash
and Supergirl totally still talk about
the big bed they still talk about the
like they're still following that same
structure yeah and it's you know not to
say there's bulletproof but it works and
it keeps working for a reason yeah I
never watched Smallville what did they
do
I don't same monster of the week what
was there uh I mean not to be talking
into what like was Buffy's like
lack of a better description smarter cuz
it did something else besides monster
the weak so super so Smallville was
pretty smart too I mean for bother yeah
it was layered do you did you watch
smoke not really Jason Mewes a huge
Smallville fan and whenever I go work on
these CW shows I'm always like man I
can't believe they're doing these shows
like based on comics that I used to read
as a kid they're getting this [ __ ] right
and so many people that work on those
shows also worked on Smallville and I
know like I guess you never watched
Smallville you know we did it for 13
[ __ ] years they point out that was
just like we're doing [ __ ] Legion of
super-heroes they're like we did it on
Smallville and in the beginning they
tell me stories too like in the
beginning you know Smallville I guess
was to show strength they had this sheet
metal which they still used to this day
that went punch it has a real metallic
look looks like real metal but like it's
light as [ __ ] paper and air cannons
were a big part of the show because
whenever somebody moves fast they blast
you with the air cannons so when they
started arrow they were like we're going
to do any of that [ __ ] man none of that
Smallville [ __ ] no air cannons on this
show until flash showdown and all of a
sudden it's all air cannons vents I was
talking to one cat who was a DP on
Smallville and now his director in like
the in the world that CW shows and he
was just like you can't get away from
the mare cannons if you're gonna do a
show about heroes you need the [ __ ]
blast you know and so they have him on
set but I was not I was not deep on
before you went deep I went deep on
Buffy I started with Firefly Firefly was
my jaw Sweden Jack was your your in that
was that was my infection vector and
then I started to just slip back into
everything else that he did so did Buffy
and then caught up with Buffy a lot of
time and then angel and then dollhouse
for reasons that defy me Eliza Eliza was
not the reason but it was just like I
was I was a Joss fanboy so I for it and
you know for better or worse it's it's a
it's a flawed show there are moments
that are great there aspects that are
awesome but on the whole
great oh really yeah that's you what
that's your final of the Buffy know of
dollhouse Oh dollhouse
yeah and I went I left my feet behind
rearview mirror all right yeah so yes we
it's so in summation are you for this
him going back and doing I mean in
twelve in common again it's the toys he
invented it's it's characters he clearly
has an affection for that hey if he can
get back in there and play with them if
make him feel better after failing
miserably a Batgirl then you go for it
mixed bag week of news for old Joss
Whedon yeah give it a minute taken
alright what else we got you know who
was getting a star on the Walk of Fame
Mark Hamill yeah absolutely finally man
I honestly was surprised he hadn't had
one yeah he is the two thousand six
hundred and thirtieth star to get a star
in the welcome now granted it's because
somebody's got to pay for that star it's
not like an Oscar like just bestowing
upon you the right yeah he's not
everyone you can't just buy a star you
actually have to have like a name and
there's a list and [ __ ] like that right
there's a vetting process but it helps
if you've got you know marketing might
of Disney behind you've gone like we
would like to do this yes last Jedi is
gonna come out on DVD how do we promote
that you know how while Kalman gets a
star on the Walk of Fame he told the
charming story about Harrison Ford told
them when they were working on Star Wars
he's like I already have a star on the
Walk of Fame
and Mark Hamill is like no you don't any
show them picture and there was a
Harrison Ford star apparently there was
a Harrison Ford not him
from like the [ __ ] nineteen tens or
twenties that had a star on the Walk of
Fame
mark small cute stories well I didn't he
have to change his name then I don't
know that's the way that works I think
but maybe this is pre sag or something I
guess because maybe he wasn't even actor
maybe he was one of the other things
like radio or some session so now which
one of them changed Michael Michael
Keaton's last name is not Keaton right
yeah is Michael Michael Douglas Michael
Douglas that's it so he he told the
story I saw on late-night one night
where he shows up at an airport and a
guy is holding a sign for he cuz he's
like I don't go by Michael Keaton
go by Michael Douglas and so when he
gets off the plane the guy pick him up
had a sign says Michael Douglas and then
Michael Keaton walks up to him and the
driver was like no you know you didn't
know what to do he's like do I just
drive Michael Keaton home and [ __ ]
Michael Douglas his story not mine but
very cute all right where we going next
they are making a Jurassic world 3
whether you want it or not
[ __ ] I saw that because I saw a date and
I'm like oh that seems far away I
thought I saw a trailer but then I
noticed I look closer I was like 3 yeah
they've already hired a writer they've
already dated the movie so they're very
bare feel very confident about 20 21
which seems far away isn't the new one
coming out now yeah no one's out in June
this looks like three years from now
yeah it wasn't three years since the
last one was it yeah was it really yeah
[ __ ] time flew by alright so I for
some reason I was like that seems a long
way away
did you like you thought you liked I had
a great time at dress world one of the
most like fun experiences I had in a
movie theatre that year when spoiler I
mean everybody must have seen it who
gives a [ __ ] by this point but when the
t-rex shows up I was a sucker for that I
was like oh my god I know him he's a
good guy what's a [ __ ] of dinosaurs
like in the first one he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
but in t2 yes like thumbs up as he dies
my god you're right they stole the
Terminator model I didn't realize that
[ __ ] I'm not talented so yeah I enjoyed
it did you I did but I I fully recognize
that it was like weaponized nostalgia
yeah it was it was literally like I'm
okay that was in the same year as force
awakens yeah like every trailer for
Jurassic world was just a [ __ ] John
Williams music and like the decapitated
decrepit gate of Jurassic Park I'm like
no I know I'm going I'm okay I know why
yeah it's all [ __ ] trickery right
it's all cinema magic so if your magic
tricks that good well I'm like y'all go
again and I know what you're doing I
know you're playing the heartstrings of
my youth but [ __ ] it like anything that
makes me feel like I felt in a movie
theater when I was a kid gets my [ __ ]
vote like that's why I love the Marvel
movies they remind me of going to see
Star Wars
and [ __ ] Raiders of the Lost Ark like
movies where I was so deeply invested in
some [ __ ] again I'm gonna des don't now
I'm a grown-ass man I shouldn't give a
[ __ ] but I'm like oh my god do you know
that [ __ ] Black Panther was really
the ending was different and bug I
almost believed what that guy said and
now I believe what she said and neither
of them [ __ ] know but it's just a
theory and [ __ ] so I'm very I'm deeply
invested in entertaining movies that
make me feel like a kid again
Marvel's crushing it Justice League did
not make me feel like a kid but it made
me happy to see characters that I've
loved since childhood up on the screen
did you see the Mark Millar had this
little he did some interview we're wrong
it's Mark Miller is it Miller yeah I
want to give him them along because but
because as an AR but it's pronounced
Miller whatever he's my boss I gotta get
it right I just turned in my first issue
of Hit Girl which is entitle the hit
girl
well you know I can't give up maybe they
want to give it a but it's it's it's fun
and I was kind of nervous about sending
it to mark because he's the only person
that's really handled that character
it's his child and and now others are
like Jeff Lemire is doing hit girl in
Canada before my arc and he liked it he
tweeted about [ __ ] digging it and
staff bless you I like it turned out
pretty good
yeah I mean he had some quote where he
talked about why Marvel Cinematic
Universe seems to be working in the DC's
extended cinematic universe isn't what
he said he said that DC heroes are
inherently unseen oh man
explain that I mean [ __ ] we've had
multiple Superman franchises and
multiple Batman franchises so he has to
back that up what does that mean he
thinks that Batman is the only one of
them that feels cinematic to him because
it's the it's the story for him
cinematic I think seems to mean human
okay in a way and so Batman's story is
very grounded in humanity okay whereas
kind of everything else is are the gods
or aliens or things that are not
tethered to the real world and so the
real world is is for him more attuned to
be in cinema now I suppose he didn't
take into account of Thor's an alien and
The Incredible Hulk is whatever and
Loki's of God
all of those things seem to apply both
right and he's catching a fair amount of
flack on the Internet's for
people are like [ __ ] yeah you don't know
what you're talking about Mark Millar
Miller yeah Mark Miller who's written
for like not only both of the big two
and written epic arcs for both of the
big two including [ __ ] one of the
greatest Superman stories ever written
read son who was then probably the the
most prolific [ __ ] creator since Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby to build a multiple
character [ __ ] universe that was then
translated to cinema and each one of
those movies have done very well so far
I gotta give him the benefit of the
doubt like he seems to know his [ __ ]
[ __ ] man he knows his business
he does I mean I I don't happen to like
the DC movies but I don't think it's
because they're inherently uncertain
matic I think he says they haven't
cracked how to make that code work yeah
I agree with you on that but all right
mark Miller
whatever you think well I get you know
honestly I give the dude a lot of
[ __ ] space man he's done it like you
know a lot of people got opinions and
[ __ ] this is a man who's like talk to
talk but he's [ __ ] walk the walk his
whole life have been about comic books
and he sold Miller world to [ __ ]
Netflix yep like he knows what he's
talking about $100,000,000 yeah all
right what do we got next
speaking of childhood nostalgia did you
play Dungeons & Dragons as a kid not
really
I loved the cartoon which I know is
nothing like the [ __ ] game and I
didn't know anybody that played the game
and also I'll be honest with you it
seemed way above my pay grade
seemed like it required a lot of Maj
ination you know what I'm saying like
there's no real like figures or
something like that like it's you know
you're making [ __ ] up and you're like
ooh now you're facing an orc and you're
like what where and they're like in your
mind [ __ ]
so so yeah but I should respect it but
I've never had people to play it with
did you I did and I kind of loved it for
like a year and a half and I goes all
about it look I had my own set of dice
and I had all the [ __ ] manuals and
[ __ ] I graph paper to be a dungeon
master and yeah I was [ __ ] deep into
it and then I my balls dropped and
looks like a sports and girls and and
D&D gotta fell by the wayside
I've got funny feelings in my dungeon my
dragon control the natural twenty please
so he gave it up I gave it up and not
because I mean I still have fond
memories of it I still have like kind of
Inklings to want to play again right but
but for me playing Dungeons and Dragons
at like 13 or 14 years old was training
for being a TV writer oh that makes
sense in that you're sitting around a
table with like seven or eight other
people you're all telling the same story
together it's collaborative storytelling
you've all establishing the rules of the
world as you go you're establishing the
things that can and cannot happen you're
you're helping to tell the story
together and that is in a very real way
all that TV writing is it's just sitting
in a room around a table with a bunch of
people you know hey what do we do next
what can we do that makes sense and Dan
isn't Dan Harmon he's a big like
Dungeons & Dragons guy yeah and he's a
big showrunner as well there's there's a
secret Club of Hollywood Dungeons &
Dragons players that I am NOT a member
of but you know I'd like to be you're
not gonna let you be if you're like I
gave it up when my balls did I don't
know but they're making dozens of
dragons movie and haven't they didn't
they do this once before they've made a
couple of like adjacent movies right
like there's a mazes and monsters thing
I think we're gonna Jaffee's mazes and
monsters the TV movie that Tom Hanks
where he says the dungeon master gone
crazy that is [ __ ] genius I remember
watching that [ __ ] cuz he was on bosom
buddies and I love the bosom buddies
before Tom max was like [ __ ] Tom Hanks
and he plays the nut bar [ __ ]
Dungeons & Dragons player that like
tries to kill all his friends I remember
that movie man but that's not Dungeons &
Dragons
no but mazes and monsters was a pretty
good ripoff name not so bad they didn't
make a D&D movie with Jeremy Irons I
think that's what I remember and I
remember Jeremy Irons was an in dungeon
master dungeon and Dragons movie but but
here is the thing that will be of
interest to you Chris McKay who did the
Lego Batman movie I'm going to direct
the desert and Dragons movies oh I like
the Lego Batman movie I thought he did
[ __ ] great all right so look
it seems like it's deep well I mean it's
not as written as say you know George RR
Martin's universe which makes it so
easily adaptable not easy but adaptable
for the HBO show for Game of Thrones but
you're in Game of Thrones adjacent
country and Hobbit adjacent country with
yeah [ __ ] Dungeons and Dragons so I
guess I guess that makes sense
who's gonna be the dragon you guys no
really I look I'll give anything a shot
I mean that's the only problem with it
is that it doesn't have the
recognizability of character the way
that Lord of the Rings does or even the
hobbit does because there's no set no
this is your Sauron like you get to make
up your names and [ __ ] right at least
you know the way most people play it
there are there have been a extended
universe of books and [ __ ] with a couple
of characters like Drizzt Do'Urden it
was a dark elf who who was incredibly
popular really yeah
did you ever watch the cartoon in the
Saturday morning cartoon yeah it was
good awesome yeah I mean it's not
followed I enjoyed the [ __ ] story it
was good there's no thunder other
barbarian but it was fine no no the
barbarian just had like Googler the mock
and that's it Princess Ariel do not
slight me my Princess Ariel all right
fair enough
it's of light all right what else we go
that is it for the news that's all the
news we gots all the news for depress
well good night kids you know what that
means when the news is over we turn to
you for the content of the show so that
means we open up the floor to cue a man
now who we got tickets for 4dx given to
us once again by our good friend Brett
Deacon and the good folks at 40x we got
10 no 10 tickets so that means we got 5
q questions give these out for right now
Black Panther is playing at all at the
40 X theaters is that true yes
and so we've got as always two sets of
tickets where five sets of tickets five
sets of two tickets so you don't go like
one please like you get to go with a
friend and [ __ ] like do we need to
understand anywhere specific yet or
that's not happening now yet that's next
time bless you all right so JC's got the
mic he will pick out the people asking
the questions we would get the QA
underway hey how are you don't forget
make it relevant to both
of us naked all right are we wearing
pants because he won't come if we I'm
out of this room if I gotta wear I would
do the Rocketeer and a heartbeat I love
The Rocketeer
but although honestly like that movies
so wonderful you wouldn't need to redo
it but in a world we just want to make
more you could start that again but I
loved it that was Joe Johnston right you
never got that chase sequence is just
too expensive doc yeah but that lends
itself for lent itself certainly to a
movie treatment like the rocket pack and
[ __ ] like that
so if that was a choice I would pick
that 10th girl oh I think I still think
I mean I I don't love that movie I love
that comic book to death Rachael tell I
think there's there's parts of that
movie that I do really like but it was
too early for it's time I didn't have
the tech to make it happen and and I
don't think they had the the sort of the
balls or maybe the wrong word they
didn't feel safe enough to push the
humor
to burst a tonne of it as far as it
needed to go so I think that yeah that
would be for me I'd really want to see
another tank robbery yes okay yes I
didn't I wrote half of it I never
finished it because I got into that
space where I was like I'm not making
movies anymore and I took like three
years off I was like I'm retired and
then all the sudden I was like I want to
make a walrus movie and then people were
like I thought you were [ __ ] retired
yeah but it got lost there in the
shuffle one day perhaps I don't want
because if I do it but it's very much
like let me see what could I compare to
well I get haven't mean I would have
said last starfighter but I guess that's
what future man is right to some degree
aren't they doing The Last Starfighter
on in German because they couldn't get
the right so lost orifice is that what
happened yeah I remember on the set of
Zack and Miri Make a Porno as pitch and
Rogen on Ranger danger and he goes oh my
god I've always wanted to remake last
starfighter and I was like really he's
like I [ __ ] love that movie I think
you could totally work today especially
like video games are huge now so I
didn't know that part like when I saw
future man I was like oh [ __ ] he finally
[ __ ] did it but I didn't know it was
because I couldn't get like I think they
went straight at last starfighter and
the screenwriter still holds the rights
and wouldn't give him up
really not to him not to Spielberg
Spielberg wanted to produce a remake and
he said no why I think maybe he's a dick
or just really real or just really rich
or really just loves it to death and
doesn't want anybody else to monkey with
it well the last starfighter it's still
I don't know if it holds up I haven't
seen it in a while I'll be honest with
you but does it hold up who's seen it
recently
does it [ __ ] that movie works I love I
love you Alex Rogan oh my god it it made
you want to spend time in an arcade that
movie if you're like what absord needs
me to fight the ko-dan armada it made
trailer park living look so good
the trailer park movie alright man that
God give it up for me got his tickets
that's great question where are we going
next JC hmmm I would love one of my
favorite things in the world is lone
wolf and cub this super long-running
manga that that house we'll see she and
[ __ ] I forget the other name but it's
wonderful it's like 22 volumes of
samurai execution and beheadings and the
father and his son sort of walking
through the wilderness being angry at
everything including God and the Buddha
and if you meet the Buddha kill the
Buddha I think that that to be able to
tell a story that deep met broad and
that wide on the same kind of canvas
that you can tell Game of Thrones on
would be amazing and I'm also here for a
ninja scroll movie if they ever make one
I'm gonna go a little deeper cuts and
and it's but it's Marvel oriented Marvel
has a character shang-chi master of Kung
Fu and in the 70s the character was
[ __ ] huge but they haven't been able
to like lift him out because he's got a
great like he's tied and bless you with
a lot of Marvel characters over history
and stuff but his his father or his
greatest enemy or both is foo Manchu and
that character is owned by somebody else
so it makes it rights wise problematic
but I would love to see that just for
the old-school Marvel fan and meet and
see that come to life
I do feel like Mark had a great point
when they announced the defenders when
they were like we're doing Iron Fist
that would have been the perfect place
it felt like you know to do an Asian
lead but they went with the other guy
who is pretty thin in every way yes but
but yeah so I bet I would go from master
master of kungfu that's us that's that's
why it's well four years being friend of
Walt Flanagan he was the one that turned
me on to master of kungfu you know it
was a religion to him there's also a
world in which and I never II think it's
a weird world to say but I think me more
is probably an Asian dude oh [ __ ] yes
and I would [ __ ] kill to see a
submariner movie who owns that it's not
Marvel's Universal I think why did they
have it I think when when Stanley came
to Hollywood in like the mid 80s and
Marvel Comics was broke he sold
everything he just literally was like
who wants what and that's how that's how
Sony gets spider-man that's how doesn't
name our part of Fantastic Four universe
I think he yeah I think he broke off on
his own in a weird way they he just
[ __ ] split up the rice and it was
also I think I read some article that
Sony had the option to buy everything
from Marvel yeah but 25 million dollars
back in the day back in the eighties man
will just take this that's great we'll
just say we'll just take your Spider Man
but you know what they weren't selling
them the lynchpin the Keystone is Kevin
Feige you need somebody with vision and
that's what they needed if they could
have got him for 25 million that would
have been a steal because not just those
characters been around forever and movie
studios have been around forever and
people have made comic movies but nobody
could crack the [ __ ] Marvel Universe
you know until to be fair let's say
blade then the x-men then spider-man but
then you're talking about everything
else like come on man like they make
movies where Iron Man is the lead that
was never gonna happen in our lifetime
and now they make movies where Thor is
good you know like [ __ ] it's amazing all
right wait yes we did you win tickets
give it up for her she want some tickets
we pass these back where we going next
Jason hey hey thank you I signed one up
here all right so what's I supposed to
do that to fanboys and a filthy casual
my favorite part of podcasting has come
up with names right it's so punk rock
like you could just [ __ ] make up any
name you want for a band fantastic
all right plug plug aside what is your
question
I think I like it'd be ridiculous after
the year of Wonder Woman and Black
Panther for them to be like we got to
see if women and black people like
movies you know clearly the answer is
like oh my god if you give anybody a
great movie they'll go see it and it's
nice if there's representation for you
so I would imagine we're gonna see a
dramatic shift in the business there's
something I just read today where I was
like oh [ __ ] that seems to be the Black
Panther effect already enough already
happening I forget what project I read
about where I was like holy [ __ ]
but yes you're gonna see a bunch of
things start happening like you know
that Batgirl story is part of that you
know like hey now this guy's gone and it
opens it up for you know a woman who
directed so I think it's gonna change
very fast they've seen how much money
they can make by appealing to people
other than the same [ __ ] people all
the time you yeah I mean I I have to
think that in every studio every
executive is being asked where's our
black panther you know and I think we're
gonna see some shitty versions of these
for a while because the desperate rush
towards the gold rush never really
actually elicits the great stuff you
have to wait for storytellers to have
the story they want to tell the
difference that we're seeing is that
storytellers like patty Jenkins like
Ryan Coogler are being supported at such
a level that that diverse story toes
have never been supported before you
know like Marvel spend more money on
black panther than they've spend on any
other solo hero movie before yeah it's
like a analogy like they made more toys
for this than they made for any other
movie so right yeah how the toys doing
the toys are doing pretty well
the toys are doing pretty well but the
idea that scale is what's the changing
defining character and and yeah I mean I
think that that Hollywood loves an
anomaly they love a thing that seems
like it only works once and they can
excuse by never having to do it again
you know and for a long time that's what
you know movies that would pop with
diverse cast would be that's what movies
that had you know female filmmakers and
female leads would be oh well it
happened that one time we can't possibly
expect to do
again but this year this calendar year
seems to be the Oh No No like get out
comes out wonder when we comes out Thor
Ragnarok comes out thunder in black
panther comes out each one of these
movies they're making hundreds and
hundreds and millions of dollars that
they didn't expect them to it's no
longer a we can't explain it we can't
possibly duplicate it's like no you
totally can
here's the roadmap but you have to
realize that it's about empowering
diverse filmmakers to tell their stories
through their lens you know cuz you look
at Black Panther that is a story that
only Ryan Kubla could have told you know
and he could I mean the Fruitvale is
also a story the only he could have told
but Marvel had to say you know what we
want that story that only you could tell
to be ours and here's all of the [ __ ]
money
you know Pixar has to say if you want to
make cocoa you know who's gonna direct
cocoa that story artist over there who's
never made a movie before but he knows
what this story is so that dude gets to
make that movie that dude gets all of
Pixar's [ __ ] resources and all of
Disney's marketing muscle behind it and
it makes 600 million dollars worldwide
and you get to show people who've never
seen themselves that way before what
that looks like and they reward that
with cash and that at the end of the day
is what Hollywood respects the most
that's the color they love they love
green do it up man
welcome mark barnard and put it on Front
Street taking all the joy out of movies
all right that gets that definitely
earned some tickets man give it up for
him his question get some tickets if
you're going to see some 40 X movies my
friend I feel like a candy man in the
Willy Wonka things like that seems like
I should have been a fun song but it's
apps all the life out of this movie
which song you can be the ring boo you
think of sex the saps the energy man
alive really yeah the whole like
grandparent orgy in that house and then
move on to the golden ticket I don't
need to see this dude it's true we never
see that dude again
nope shows up sings a song moves on I
like the song though not a bad song
Sammy Davis does it better
true [ __ ] yeah
there's nothing that Ryan Coogler can't
director won't be offered right now like
it doesn't even matter if he was suited
for the job or not like he's made a
movie that's gonna make a billion bucks
he will be offered the keys to the
kingdom they'll have his choice and why
if they were like a man you wanna do
Star Wars movie I mean I could see him
going yeah I mean I don't know him at
all but like I could also see him going
like I got this going on over here I'm
fine I have my own Star Wars you know
what I'm saying but yes I think he'll be
all for me yeah I mean bond has a weird
thing where I mean it's it's an
unwritten rule that only directors of
British descent can in some way make it
like every director of a James Bond
movies been British alright yeah
soup-to-nuts like evenly Tama Hari was
Australian which is technically a common
colonizer yeah so now do they let a kid
from Auckland make a Bond movie I don't
know but after I see that Casino scene
in he didn't make a Bond movie that's
his bonding yeah yeah Danny Boyle is the
frontrunner to do the next Bond these
great directors and I think I think Ryan
can do whatever he wants to do I think
Ryan is also of the light one for the
one for me mode so the next movies
making is about a schoolteacher in
Oakland starring Michael B Jordan and it
won't cost you in a million dollars but
the true yeah yeah because I keep
they're the [ __ ] Scorsese in De Niro
I like to act he likes to direct him
yeah so but yes whatever he wants
tomorrow they will give him they will
offer him keys the kingdom are given
anybody that can make people money you
know and make jigs they assume they'll
be able to repeat that magic trick for
the rest of their career and sometimes
they will like Steven spills early and
sometimes you know what they won't but
Ryan seems like he will Creed I mean
like everyone's talking about oh my god
Black Panther proves but for me I'm like
Creed was a big-budget movie that took a
franchise that like made probably a
billion dollars at least over the course
of its lifetime all those Rocky movies
because they weren't making the crazy
money movies make these days but over
years in home video probably made a mil
of billion bucks and he breathed life
into that was never gonna [ __ ] happen
again yeah like is certainly like maybe
no I don't think like [ __ ] Stallone
had it in him I don't think he was
thinking yeah one day I'll do another
rocky he seemed to do is last rocky and
he was done so he proved that he can
like breathe new life into something and
make money with a franchise black
panther is just further proof of much of
the same so yeah I'll be able to do
whatever he wants from now until the end
of time and he's 31 years old so he's
got all the time all the [ __ ] time
he's made three movies each one those
movies have been like 94% on Rotten
Tomatoes like it's it's the world is his
[ __ ] oyster good friend he made a
great flick that's a wonderful [ __ ]
movie that black panther it's really
[ __ ] enjoyable yeah the [ __ ] Creed
is a minor miracle like I gave a [ __ ]
about rocky and I was so done with that
[ __ ] and all of a sudden I was like I
care I want him to get up the steps but
I cared more about [ __ ] Creed oh
[ __ ] my favorite moment in that
movies when he's out cold they do the
fast montage and then they show his dad
he goes blue and [ __ ] pops up Oh
[ __ ] any dad MoMA in a movie that you
know like [ __ ] feel the dreams daddy
wanted for casual my girl
that added for me I did you to bring the
boy home oh my god all right yes that
get some tickets give that man some
tickets and we got one set of tickets
left to go where we going
hi fire away
okay pork roll all the way Taylor ham is
a name for snobs oh my god this is like
a multi-part question all right let's do
it first so Marvel kills off their
villains you're right I hadn't really
thought about that they do except for
Loki yeah [ __ ] because they know we
know he's gonna be a hero before it's
all said and done he's already been a
hero a couple times but you know he's
gonna go out nobly I've been watching
Thor Ragnarok over and over because it's
on home video now and [ __ ] like I think
his death scene is meant to foreshadow
his death scene that's my guess like I
think I not be surprised if we saw a
scene very much like where he's like
make sure they put up a statue with the
bendy hole so yeah you're right he's the
villain that keeps getting the past and
the vulture got to live as well but yeah
[ __ ] it they even killed claw and [ __ ]
kill Raven but Red Skull is still out
there Hugo Weaving will never play it
again he's not interested right he hated
it or whatever he said that publicly a
few times you might write like he's like
oh [ __ ] these things are making money I
love Marvel make mine Marvel but yeah
that's somebody who could easily recast
right because at this point he's no
longer the the other guy he's total Red
Skull who would I make the Red Skull I
mean the obvious choice for me is like
Fassbender he's already [ __ ] magneto
you know he could pull off the leading
villain guy and I think he speaks German
so you're halfway there man he's tall
there's put some makeup on it's all good
find me a skarsgård there's got to be
like Peter skarsgård yeah but bill who
played the clown
any wise is [ __ ] tall - I met him at
Sundance and I a little he was like a
head taller than me had to look up at
him yeah so he could totally be that guy
he's on the castle rock show and he's
got a very expressive face as well he's
on the castle rock she's on the castle
when does that start
summer 2018 if I if I think my post
comic-con because they'll Morgan say
they didn't do a big convention yeah
thing there yeah what what is that what
your zone yeah episode 5 I'm so fine you
got your name on it yeah is it you solo
you sure credit I'm sharing credit with
who a guy named Vinnie Wilhelm this is a
big deal for you not a black guy you
look at people in life how they look at
me man is that um is that your fur
you've had your name on yeah TV Chris
before this is a big deal this is a big
deal Stephen King things the whole
[ __ ] thing part of the writers room
from the job and stuff it's huge man
[ __ ] huge hopefully more leads to
more are they talking about doing
another season they haven't talked about
it yet but if I had to if I had to guess
an educated guess I would say yes me and
Mark are cooking up something hopefully
[ __ ] works we'll let you know more as
it unfolds knock on wood yeah but you
know I've sat next to mark now for many
episodes of fat man I'm Batman
and I hear you say it over and over
again you hear me say it like mine he's
[ __ ] smart he knows I do story in
[ __ ]
so whenever I need story I turned to him
and there's a thing that we've been
working on which might pan out so we'll
let you know how that goes was that the
last question is that that was the last
question give that mass of tickets he
got some did you you picked right guard
guard
did we answer them all yes it was the
final one was who would plan that was
every and oh okay and who were the last
two Mandarin and Fang Fang Foom okay so
will they ever do the real Mandarin as
opposed to the one that we saw in Iron
Man 3 and they hinted at it and that
little cutscene they put on the DVD
where what's the same Sam Rockwell's
went to jail or something like that or
what's his name Ben Ben Kingsley went to
jail and Sam Rockwell was in jail
and then somebody mentioned something
about the real Mandarin right I don't
know man I mean they're certainly not
going to do it with Robert Downey jr. I
think I think Tony Stark's like time is
limited I don't think he's gonna we're
never gonna see his another series of
Iron Man movies where he's the guy is
what it feels like they keep warning us
get ready everyone's gonna [ __ ] die
Avengers like so I think he might be one
of them cuz he's the guy that gets two
deaths right Tony Stark gets to die
nobly to save the Marvel Universe and
then he gets to live on as the voice in
the suit if they want to go that route
he could totally Tony downloaded his
consciousness into the suit so he
becomes the new Jarvis Jarvis over
Friday as who it is now what happens to
Friday that's [ __ ] anybody's guess
she's like no mr. stark Andy replaces
her so you know what I saw did you ever
see Blade Runner 20 I did yeah I finally
[ __ ] caught up to it and for you know
since it came out I was like I don't
have six weeks to watch a movie because
it was like three hours so one night I
had three hours and I was like [ __ ] it
let's go for it
and we watched it and it was more of a
duty like I was like I have to watch
this because I'm a filmmaker and
filmmakers like Blade Runner and [ __ ]
like that but once it started I was
actually [ __ ] in I thought he made a
dope flick man like he's still like
Dinny
yeah like over four four four four
however [ __ ] many movies he's made
II's crack the code and it was a pretty
good mystery like even though like I it
wasn't what I thought it would be and I
was I was kind of delighted by the whole
thing and I forget where I brought it up
because there's something specific and
it was it triggered my memory about
Mandarin Mandarin I forget starts dying
to deaths Tony Stark dying to death oh
yes well done in in in the movie it's
dope if you haven't seen it like they
sell a product in the movie I forget was
joy Jewish wah or something like that
and it's kind of like in you know her
that movie he had the digital assistant
who was always in his ear but she's a
holograph form that comes to life and
like could talk to him and stuff like
that but she's a program
the more time you spend with the program
the more she knows you so the more
realistic she becomes and stuff like
that and at one point they you know
she's he's like she goes put me on the
the home like she's on the home system
but she's like put me on the travel mode
thing which is dangerous like upload
everything to this thing because then if
something happens to that the idea is
she's [ __ ] and so and she's just again
at [ __ ] digital program and [ __ ] but
she spent so much time with Ryan Gosling
that she you know knows him and they
have this relationship and there's a
moment in the movie spoilers were
[ __ ] like you know that is threatened
her whole existence is threatened and I
felt like incredibly moved was like
don't kill her in the night to stop and
be like number one
she's digital number two this is a movie
shut up you know and just [ __ ] pig
back but it was so well done that like I
got invested to the point where I was
like oh I was bummed out like or you
know I don't want spoiler she gets
[ __ ] killed and so like I was like I
don't want to spoil it but I'm going I
got it but it was pretty it was dope man
if you haven't seen Blade Runner yet
yeah and I think he might win for for
cinematography Deakins yeah like it
seems to be his year he's been nominated
multiple times
still hasn't won it but that movie was
beautiful from start to finish yeah
we're not gonna get to do an Oscar
prognostication prognostication episode
because anything the next time was the
6th after the Oscars right but you're
doing a whole [ __ ] IMDB jammy-jam
right I am for IMDB they're doing like a
watching party it's called the IMDB
viewing party or something and so
there's a bhaskar pre-show and then
during the breaks of the Oscar telecast
we come back and talk to people and [ __ ]
like that I'm most excited I look I'm
excited to the whole thing but I get to
talk to Tatum O'Neal
at one point and I you know [ __ ] The
Bad News Bears shaped my life Engelbert
shaked me particularly but the whole
[ __ ] movie shaped my life so I look
forward to [ __ ] talking her she won
an Oscar for Paper Moon she was a
youngest person I think to everyone in
Oscar so is a bunch of people will be
talking to that night between breaks and
then after the show there's like a wrap
up stuff but it's gonna be good and to
the point where I cut my hair because I
was growing it out
really really
for like last year and then I was like
you know what this looks like [ __ ] so I
just cut it and I also a part of the
reason I was growing it long as I was
willing the budget for Jay and Silent
Bob reboot to happen I was like by the
time my hair is long enough to be silent
Bob will probably have the money and you
know it's coming it's just like still
slow going at you and I said to myself
if you cut your [ __ ] hair for sure
the money's gonna come through because
then that means like all that [ __ ]
work god damn it but I'm gonna [ __ ] as
long as we have the budget I'll wear
[ __ ] fake hair so I cut my hair to
get ready and I'm wearing a tux for the
exam yeah I just [ __ ] up so I don't
think I'm wearing pants though I'm
wearing jeans right I mean you've got a
man's man can't wear [ __ ] pants but
yeah I'll be wearing from the waist up
I'll be all tux and from the waist down
total jersey but that'll be happening
next week on on Sunday yes thank you for
the plug I would have totally spaced on
that so we won't have a show before them
now what do you thinks gonna win
get out you feeling it I'm feeling
better picture I think so it's gonna
beat shape of water chamber water has
been taking all the awards in advance I
think so
I think yelling wins Best Director and
get out wins best movie Wow Wow to be
honest with you like I I love shape of
water like is a beautiful movie I think
it was my favorite movie I think it was
originally your favorite moment here too
and it's cinematic and [ __ ] like that
but in terms of the movie that is
impactful game-changing of the moment
yes I would say hands down it feels like
get out I wonder if that's guy wonderful
that'll happen maybe the same thing this
year like it was last year with like
shape of water weight get out no for
real get every [ __ ] year where
somebody's like we won and they're like
no you didn't get off the [ __ ] stage
ladies and gentlemen of the cantina scum
and villainy Cantina have you had a good
time this evening
I cannot thank you enough for coming out
tonight man as always we'll be here
when's the next show do you remember
March 6 March 6 we'll be right back here
this comin villany Cantina doing fat man
on Batman again it was tough I liked
going to do flash quite a bit but it was
actually tough to not do this show for a
few weeks and I watched people on
Twitter be like what happened a fat man
on Batman I'm like nothing I'm a flash
man Batman's a flash man so hopefully
folks didn't think we gave up the show
or anything like that because I
seriously love doing the shows my one of
my favorite of the podcast you know I
like podcasts where I get to talk about
myself a lot obviously they're a bunch
of them but I like podcasts where I talk
about other people's [ __ ] because long
before I was a filmmaker a storyteller I
just liked other people's [ __ ] as a fan
I just loved movies and [ __ ] so the idea
coming here sitting around a bunch of
people who are getting drunk while we
talk about movies is a glorious thing I
can't believe we live in this amazing
[ __ ] world so I thank you all for
coming out and being here at the show
tonight
and most of all I thank my co-host give
it up for the amazing mr. mark Bernardo
come on and that is Batman I'm Batman
for this week I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark
barnard tune in next week same fad time
same fat channel SModcast calm or
YouTube becomes less Kevin Smith
[Applause]
[Music]